RICH IANNONE: So we got gt.
We got palmerpenguins.
Now we got the dataset
penguins pipe down the gt.
And in your viewer, you get the
table, which is pretty sweet.
You don't have to do too much
just to get a basic table.
Right?
So I just move this out
a bit so we can actually
see more of the table.
Great, great.
So say you wanted to do things
like make this look nice,
like maybe add a title,
because titles are nice,
because it tells you what's
going on in the table.
So we can actually do
that with a tab header.
And then there's an
option right there.
You just see seem in,
like, the pop up title.
Subtitles seem to be optional.
I like a subtitle sometimes.
But I'll put in title--
I'll put it in the
penguins dataset.
All right.
And so we could just run
it like that as it is.
But we have this cool
thing called Markdown.
So we can actually
use that, too.
You just have to
wrap this with md.
Then you can do cool
things like use Markdown.
And now we can have like
these back ticks to say, like,
this is going to be
in this code font.
And there we go.
Instantly, you can just
sort of work iteratively
and see the result
on the other side.
And this is kind of nice,
because you can sort of
learn how to make tables.
And when it comes to the
time to publish these tables,
like, put them in our Markdown
document or a Word document,
you're very practiced up.
This will just
become second nature.
So yeah.
Tab header.
That gives you titles.
Let's actually
put a subtitle in,
because that's kind of sweet.
Subtitle we want
to use Markdown,
because it's a good thing.
So what's something we can say
about the penguins dataset?
Three years, three
years of data.
That's not bad.
On penguins on three islands.
We can meet this long, because
the subtitle is pretty small.
So we're using Markdown.
Let's not let that go to waste.
So let's actually
accentuate something here.
Not bad, but with two asterisks
on each side of three.
We can make that bold.
And just for fun, and just
to prove that it works,
we can do this in italics.
So let's run this whole thing.
Not too shabby.
So we get Markdown
treatment here it.
Just appears.
And by default,
it's just centered.
I mean, that's a cool thing.
We can also make it left
aligned if you want that,
but we can get that
a little bit later.
Never mind.
Let's do it now, because
no time like the present.
So opt table,
align table header.
OK, great.
So now we just have to say
align equals left for that, sort
of, nice left aligned look.
Actually, it looks more
pro than before, actually,
for some reason.
I really like it.
OK.
So that is how to make a title,
like a header on a table.
So now we're saying like--
now we're thinking like, OK.
We have all this data.
That's a lot for
a summary table.
Let's actually just make
a summary table, right?
This is a lot to chew on.
It's basically just, like,
raw data in lots of ways.
So the cool thing
is we have things
like the tidyverse, like
dplyr, tidyr, all that stuff.
I'm going to load
in the tidyverse.
Great.
And we can do stuff to penguins
before we put it in the gt.
So we could do things like all
the fun stuff, like group by--
we can group by, maybe, species.
Let's do that.
OK, great.
And then we'll do a summarize.
Here's the thing.
I don't even know
what to summarize.
How about the mean
body mass and mean--
just means.
We'll just do some
means, means everywhere.
Fine.
Let's just do one, bill length.
And let's just see if
this even works with funs.
Whoa, whoa.
OK, good.
Going with it, maybe.
So we have to do--
OK, so let's go move this
back to where it was.
And there's like an na.
Oh, yeah.
It's sort of like the mean.
It's going to be like
this where we have na.
I'm totally not sure if
that's going to work.
That totally works.
OK, good.
OK, so we're doing this.
So we can do a mean.
I'm not sure how you
do multiple functions.
I think it might be list.
I'm not sure if you just put--
you know what?
I'm not going to
follow up with that.
I'm going to put a
bunch of rs in here.
And away we go.
OK.
So we'll do bill
length, bill depth.
Great.
So let's do flipper--
yeah, we'll make it
a bunch of things.
Yeah.
I mean I'd probably
say, like, just indices,
like, three to like--
I like to make things
hard for myself.
OK.
So flipper.
No matches?
Seriously?
OK.
And now a body mass g.
Great.
I think that'll do it.
OK.
So now we got this.
Excellent.
So now we have a summary table.
OK, so now we got this.
This is kind of cool.
So we have our summary table.
It is up here.
Let me make this a
little bit bigger.
Now you just see it all.
And we have species, and we
have all the data involved.
The cool thing about gt is it
allows you to put things, like,
in a stub.
So these are kind of
like labels for a row.
So you can do something
called rowname_col
and we can put species in there
like that, that column name.
And the great
thing about that is
that it just sets it
off, puts it to the left,
and sets it off with
an automatic order.
And there's nothing about that
either, which you can change.
But it's nice,
because you can just
have this as, like- it
looks more like a table
than just it being not
separate like that.
So we do that by
rowname_col equals species.
So this is still cool.
We can actually
change the title,
so it's like summary of
the penguins dataset.
It's actually a little
more interesting.
And we cannot-- this is no
longer valid, I don't think.
Three years of data on--
I would say, like,
maybe uses three years
of data on penguins
on three islands.
Maybe that's a bit
more correct to say.
So now if we run this
whole thing, let me guess.
Here?
OK, great.
We could run this
whole thing now.
So now we get this.
Uses three years of
data, and you can always
change things like
the title like so
and run it again pretty quickly.
So now we sort of see the
beginnings of a nicer table.
The only problem we have
is the column labels
look not so great.
I mean, they're great for,
like, your tables and deplyr,
but they're not so
great for, like,
summary tables you're
going to present on people.
So maybe we can make those nice.
We can totally do that with
something called cols_label.
OK.
So if we do bill length,
here we go on complete.
And then put equal sign,
then in quotes, the thing
you want to change
it to, that works.
And you just have a bunch of
those, like, sort of set off.
Like, it's a list,
essentially, without having
a list around it.
So we could just
say bill length.
And the cool thing is we
can do things like this
and put in mm below.
Let's see if I'm
right about that.
So we're going to tie us
all together with that.
No.
OK, not quite.
The thing we have to
do is put md around it,
because the br tag is HTML, and
Markdown, it recognizes HTML.
So that's a sort
of a good pairing.
There we go.
So now we have bill
length, no brs.
We probably want a
comma, as we often see.
That will be nice to sort
of separate the links apart.
So now we have bill length, mm.
And it looks a bit nicer.
It's a bit more
narrow, which is great.
And we could do the
same thing for the rest.
So we just have to sort of
copy this as a template,
work down, change it.
So now we're going
to change depth here.
Depth.
And then this will become depth.
Same sort of things apply.
Add comas where you need them.
And next one should
be flipper length.
Great.
And one more.
Body mass g.
OK.
Great.
Mass, comma br, then g.
Let's see how this looks,
just by running on this code.
Not bad.
It's looking pretty good.
It's looking more table
like, a little bit less,
you know, like, wide.
So these are just some
cool things you could do.
The numbers, you won't
need that many digits,
like, after a decimal point.
That's a lot.
So gt comes with a whole ton
of these formatting functions.
They all begin with fmt.
So you see a few of them here.
The thing you really want
here is format number,
which has just a plethora
of options that you can use.
So we'll go with that.
And just by using
the defaults, it's
like two digits off your
decimal place all the way down,
and it operates on columns.
So you need to have
that, absolutely.
And the cool thing is,
you can borrow things
from deplyr, the tidyverse.
You can use everything, because
all the columns here that
are in the data are numeric.
So you totally use that.
Great.
And the other cool
thing about it
is that, if you use format
number, it comes with these--
it uses these digit
separators, basically, commas.
And that just gets
put in where it needs
to be put in automatically.
So that's kind of cool.
| another cool thing
is that this might not
be what you want, body mass g.
Maybe you want kilograms.
So we can actually do that.
So we can put another
formatter function in,
which is format number again.
And we can target just
the body mass column.
So to do that, we use, just,
like, the original column
name like this, body
mass g, like so.
But now we're going
to use options.
We're going to do something
a bit more interesting.
We're going to do something--
use an option called scale_by.
In this case, we
want it in kilograms,
so we're going to scale
it by one over 1,000.
So we're going to
divide it by 1,000.
Cool.
So let's do that.
Now we have it in kilograms.
So we're going to go back,
change the label to be kg.
And this is kind
of nice, because it
takes all those digits, sort of
compresses it down to something
that's a bit more readable.
We have less digits overall.
And, you know, if
you're starting with g,
you might as well go to kg.
Like, it's not a stretch
of the imagination.
So you can actually
scale numbers
with the formatters in
gt, which is kind of cool.
Now we have this.
We may notice there's a few
things that are kind of, like,
not great.
Like, for one thing--
this probably just
bothers me-- but,
like, the width of these
columns is not the same across.
It's basically governed by the
width of the largest label.
In this case,
flipper length makes
the column much more wider.
But we can change that.
We can change anything.
We can go to use this function
called cols_width right there.
And what we can do is we
can select the columns.
I believe it's going to be--
OK.
You can use tySelect
on the left side.
So we can do things like--
OK.
So we can use this right here.
We can use just this
bars list, I think.
OK.
Like so.
We're going to bring that down
like this, because we just
need the names
itself, not in quotes.
Oh, I apologize.
We actually-- no, that's right.
Those are the original names.
So we get like this.
And then on the
right side, we're
going to put in width value.
So we can use this px
helper function if you want.
And it just means that
any value put in there
is going to a mixed list.
It's the same thing
as writing, like,
in quotes some number with
px to the right of it.
So let's put in, like, 50 to see
where it starts, and we'll just
copy that down to
each of these like so
and see what it gets us.
No.
OK, so I got that wrong.
Instead of equals signs,
we should be using this.
Great.
OK, let's try this out.
OK, not bad.
I mean, a little bit
small, but the cool thing
is we can stretch this out.
So you can make this
80, for instance.
And then we get it, like, a
width that's kind of nice.
Oh, not quite right.
Let's make this even
bigger, 120, I think.
There we go, and we may
even bring it down a bit.
It's all, like, iterative.
You're going to adjust
things as you go.
Luckily, it's pretty fast.
There's almost no time cost.
I think we missed
the sweet spot here.
I think it's going to be
like 110 or thereabouts
where, like, things
stop wrapping.
Maybe 120 was good.
OK.
I'm going to go with this.
This is not bad.
So now we have all the columns,
like, at least in the data part
being of the same width,
which is kind of nice.
It kind of leaves your
eye in a nice way.
Like, each of these
numbers are spaced out.
They have similar speeds between
them, which is kind of cool.
And you can also do the same
thing for the stub, as well.
You just use it to
orient everything.
And that means, in this
case, everything else.
And we can make
that a bit bigger.
I'm not sure what it's starting
at, but if you just do 60,
it's definitely going
to change things.
And I'm going the
wrong direction.
Maybe you want that to be 100.
And there we are.
Now we have an idea as our table
with the width that we want it.
So we're basically focusing
on presentation here,
and we're trying to make
it look good, I guess.
But these are tricks you
can do pretty simply.
You just have to--
and, of course, you
need to use tySelect here.
You have a statement
that works nicely
for all these four columns.
That works.
You have to use on
the left side there
and just use px equals
120 for all of them.
So that's that.
So say you want
to add some notes.
And we add a pair section, but
what about a footnote section?
So we can definitely have that.
And there's two ways to
put stuff in the footer.
We can use tab_source_note.
Great.
These are just general notes
that you pop into the bottom.
And a good thing we can
say here, or put in,
is where the dataset comes from.
OK.
So dataset is from the
palmerpenguins package.
And we can just say our package,
as well, and put a period.
We're in a little bit of space.
I'm going to just
line break here.
And we can try that
out, but I know
there's going be a mistake.
And the mistake is that we're
using Markdown when, really, we
didn't declare it.
So in all these parts, all these
opportunities to put in text,
we can definitely use
md helper function.
And it just means
interpret it as Markdown.
And any output
format you use will
render that to be
looking nice like the way
you want it to look.
And we may even do a thing like
accentuate r, just like this.
Sort of tense up a bit.
There we go.
So that's just
like a source note.
Basically, it's
a note that's not
tied into any particular
place in the table,
but we can do that.
We can use tab_footnote.
And this takes in,
like, two arguments.
So in the previous one, you
just had to put in a note.
In this case, you have to put it
in the note, plus what location
the note was referring to.
So let's add the footnote first.
And I guess now's a good time to
talk about what we can actually
point out.
We can just say, like,
Gentoo looks to be,
like, the biggest
penguin by most accounts.
I mean, not so much in
bill length and bill
depth, but certainly,
flipper length and body mass.
The Gentoo is,
like, reign supreme,
I guess, amongst these three.
So let's just do that.
Let's just say, like,
Gentoo is largest.
I'll just say the largest of
the three penguins studied.
Great.
So that's great.
That's the note that's
going to appear tomorrow.
So where are we going
to attach this to?
I mean, the most
logical place in my mind
would be, like, the label
itself or Gentoo right here.
So in this step.
So in locations, we can use this
huge amount of location helper
functions, and they
all begin with cells.
And you see the auto pop,
this or the auto help,
shows us, gives us a guide as
to which ones are available.
In this case, you
want cell_stub.
So it's going to appear
a little bit lower.
There we are.
And if you just take a
look on the right side,
we got rows is
the only argument.
So in this case, we want
to say rows equals Gentoo.
We just want to repeat the
label that's in the stub.
OK.
Great, so let's run this.
Great.
There's our first footnote.
It's really great.
So we have, as
footnotes often do,
they have some sort of
glyph, like for where
the note is referring to.
And there's a note right there.
So the footnotes, the
numbered footnotes, they
appear above the source
notes, and it's a cool thing.
We can also change the way the--
the glyphs themselves.
We can use opt for note marks.
And we can say marks could be
something other than numbers.
It could be letters.
So if we do that,
we begin with A.
And we can do capital
letters like so.
And going further, we could
have a custom set of marks.
So you might do
star, double star,
and who knows what you have?
If you have any source set,
it'll just run through the set.
So we can do that, as well.
There we go.
So you can really
change the marks
to be whatever you want to
be, which is super nice.
So that is the first footnote.
I'm going to take
this part out, just
to demonstrate the
order of footnotes.
So the cool thing
about gt is that you
don't have to manually
manage your footnotes.
You can just go nuts with adding
tab_footnote, tab_footnote,
and gt will handle
the ordering and all
the other, sort
of, small details
when it comes to footnotes.
So we can say things like--
we can elaborate on what,
say, flipper length is.
I mean, we can say in a
footnote, flipper length is--
I don't know the details
about the dataset
or how the data was acquired.
But we can say
flipper length was
measured with a tape measure.
Let's be a bit silly here.
Maybe it was.
Who knows?
This is maybe a
little bit of fiction.
OK.
So let's say that's true.
Flipper length was measured
with a tape measure.
So the note would appear
right here on the column label
itself, flipper length.
So cool.
We can do that.
We could say locations
equals cells,
and autocomplete is
your friend here.
It'll be cells_column_labels.
It just takes the
columns argument.
And again, we just put
in the column name.
So I'm going to
type that all out.
Columns equals flipper.
Hit autocomplete again, and
we're going to run this.
There we are.
So before we had one
where Gentoo was,
now it's number two,
because that appears later,
which is kind of cool.
We didn't have to,
sort of, match that.
We didn't have to say
what the glyph was.
Gt does a sensible thing
of, like, indexing footnotes
from top to bottom,
left to right,
so we don't have to worry
about things like that.
And here's another
really cool thing.
Say, for instance, you wanted
two footnotes on the same spot.
OK.
So tab_footnotes.
So we'll add
additional note about--
this is very silly.
I'm going to copy this whole
thing, because it's going
to be on the same location.
We'll say something like, the
tape measure, unfortunately,
suffered some frost
damage, because they
were in the Antarctic,
so things happen.
So yeah.
Maybe they had to be,
like, disclose everything.
OK.
So now we have two notes
on the same column label.
So what's going to happen?
It seems like some
sort of conflict,
but no, gt handle that.
You can just run this.
We get one and two.
So there's, basically, two
notes, two different notes.
They alight to this same cell.
And then Gentoo is number
three, which is great.
But it'll handle multiple notes.
And the cool thing
is you can even
have a list of
cell column labels,
or-- sorry-- of locations.
So we can have this note
being applied to more stuff.
So you can say, cells_data.
Or I think it's cells_body.
And we want columns to be the
same column, flipper length.
And basically, what
it's going to do now
is it's going to put the note,
the glyph, on the column label
and all of the values
in that column.
So if we run this,
you see that, too,
is repeated down, because the
tape measure is compromised.
So basically, we're just
putting the notes, the glyphs,
on the actual values
themselves, too.
It's a bit silly,
but I just want
to show you that footnotes,
it's very flexible.
It does the right
thing most of the time.
Nobody's ever complained
about it, which is good news.
And I think people
actually like it,
because they didn't
complain about it.
So that is good.
So footnotes work,
is what I'm saying.
So what if you wanted to
highlight a certain bit of data
in this table?
OK.
We can totally do that, too.
We can use tab_style.
OK.
And it operates
under the same sort
of principles as tab_footnote.
I mean, it has locations, and
we use the same location number
functions.
So let's say, for instance,
for whatever reason,
we wanted highlight the entire
row of the Gentoo penguin, just
the data.
I don't know why.
But say you wanted to do that.
OK, so we can do that.
So we do cells_body.
Great.
We use columns
equals everything.
Great.
But in this case, you want rows
to be limited to just Gentoo.
OK.
This looks solid,
but it just means
that we're going to target
all the columns, but just
the rows and all those columns
that correspond to Gentoo.
And that, of course,
is in the stub.
When you have something
in the stub that's
an additional advantage, you
can use the rows argument more
precisely.
You can actually
just use the labels,
provided that they're unique.
And most of the time,
they are, otherwise
it would be a little
bit less value.
I'd say.
OK, great.
So we have that.
Now we have the
cells_body statement.
Great.
So now what are we
going to do about it?
We're going to,
actually, add a style.
Great.
So we have a bunch of
style helper functions.
So basically, tab_style
uses two different types
of helper functions, one
in locations, one style.
In this case, it's
singular cell.
And in this case, you
want to fill the cells
with some sort of color.
There's a default, but I'm
going to go with color,
and I'm going to go with like
steel blue, if I can spell it.
There we go.
And let's just see this work.
So what I'm expecting to
see is the Gentoo row,
just the data cells will have
that color in the background.
And it worked.
That's great.
So now we have that right there.
We can change the color.
It accepts all color
names, which is great.
Light blue, I
believe, is a color.
That looks quite a bit nicer.
And we can also use text
colors, if you know them.
So you can do--
I don't know them.
Let's try it.
Let's try some random one here.
Let's see if this
gives us anything nice.
Not bad.
I just guessed at that.
OK, that worked out pretty well.
But if you wanted to
say, for instance, you
had too dark of a
color, and you wanted
to have maximized contrast,
like, make this the text white,
for instance, you
can really do that.
You can have multiple styles
for the same certain location.
So we can close down the list.
Cell_fill is that.
And now we can use cell_text
and change the color of the text
to be white.
We'll have this.
I'll just tie this up a little
bit so it looks a bit better.
OK.
So in this case, I have
the cell_fill color,
and then using a text color,
which is being changed.
Great.
Not too bad.
So now we have better contrast,
because we chose a darker
background color.
So that is that.
So you can definitely do things
like style certain cells.
This applies to everything.
You can style the header.
You can style the footer.
You can style to set stub.
Every single location
here is stylable.
One more thing, just
to complete this table,
we have this top left corner
here that's customarily empty.
I mean, the default
is that it's empty.
But we can change that.
There's a special function
just for adding content
to that top left corner.
It's called tab_stubhead.
And it just accepts the label.
And as we often do, we can use
Markdown to make that nice.
And in this case, it's
kind of a wild card.
You can describe
either the columns.
You can describe the rows.
You can describe both.
It's up to you.
I'm going to put
in penguin, so I'm
going to treat it
more like a column.
So I'm just going to
say penguin species.
Great.
So I'm going to add that in,
and there it is in the top left.
So you can definitely use
that once empty corner.
You just have to remember
the functioning tab_stubhead.
It's low on argument, so it's
not too difficult to use.
You'll get it.
And that's my nice
table, and there's
tons and tons of options.
So say you wanted to
change the table font.
You can do that with this opt
function called opt_table_font.
This is a pretty popular option
because, sometimes the default
font is not what you want.
And the great thing
about this opt_table_font
is you could use local fonts.
Say you have Helvetica
on your machine.
You can totally use that,
and it changes the look.
Let's say you want something
that is not on your machine,
maybe part of Google Fonts.
You could use google_font,
then choose a font
from their service, as
long as you know the name.
It's not too hard to do.
So Montserrat is one of them.
Now let's use that.
Great.
And it totally changed.
And we have all sorts
of options here.
We have things like the
weight can be changed.
Usually, these are
numbered weights,
so we can change it to be
heavier, like, say, 600.
There we go.
So we definitely see that now.
And you'd have to go to
the Google Fonts page
to see what weight
ranges are available.
But that can be totally used.
There's options,
too, like styles.
You can choose, like, italic,
oblique, things like that.
Let's actually do that,
see if that works.
There we go.
So everything was changed
to, like, the italic version
of the font.
So what I'm going to do
is I'm going to take out
this tab_style thing for now.
I'm going to comment
it out, because I'm
going to apply our own
style based on data color.
OK.
So data color-- this is what I
do every time I use data color.
It's really hard to
use, because it requires
that you use functions
within the function,
like function calls, and
they're not even gt functions.
They're functions from
the scales package.
So I would always use the help.
I'll go to data color, like so.
And then, of course, it
tells you what it does.
And like all the help
files, it gives you
the visuals, showing
what it does,
which are paired
to the examples.
But yeah.
My point is, I would go
to the example that works,
and then just take
it and go from there.
So in this case,
what we have here is,
it's working on a single column.
And we have the colors argument.
It requires a function col.
Typically, it's from scales,
and the help tells
you about this.
But I'm just going
to copy this in,
because it's much
easier to show than it
is to explain it beforehand.
And what it's
going to do-- we're
going to adapt this to
particular example here.
So if you look at
your viewer again,
we have these ones right here.
We have columns right there.
So I'm going to say columns are
going to be the same as before.
So I'm going to choose--
maybe for the sake
of brevity, I'm
going to choose just two
columns, bill length and bill
depth.
Great.
So now, the colors will be--
will basically be
colorized according
to the values in the columns.
That's great.
So we're going to use
col_numeric to create our,
sort of, like, set
of colors that we're
going to interpolate through.
So the range is going
to be the domain.
And we can have this being null,
and that just sets the domain
to the range of the values.
But I kind of like actually
signing the domain.
So I'm going to use
c equals 30, and then
50 for the upper
part of the range.
And then I'm going to set,
like, maybe three colors,
because it's going to
be like 30, 40, and 50.
So I'm just going to choose
red, orange, green and omit
the blue.
Great, great.
So let's see if
this actually works.
The key thing is will
this actually work.
OK.
And it does sort of work.
The reason why it
doesn't work here
is because this is
actually out of range.
So if you want to have
different domains,
we can definitely do that with
multiple cols of data color,
or we can set this
to null, like that.
And again, this
domain is, actually,
inside the scale's
col_numeric function call.
So a little tricky, but when
it works, it works awesomely.
So this will be nice,
because this will
treat each column separately.
Actually, no.
It treats it holistically.
So but the point being, if
you just had, say, like,
bill length here, this
would be much more nicer.
Then we can actually
choose the domains
that make more sense for
the particular type of data
we have in there.
Let's do 30, 50.
There we go.
So we can see here
that red is not really
going to be in the picture,
because we're pretty far
away from 30.
We're getting more close to
orange, which is sitting at 40,
and then green sits at 50,
which we do see quite a bit
of in Chinstrap and Gentoo.
But now that we
have a template, we
can actually do this for
each and every column,
just tweaking the
values of domain.
So for instance, we want
to do this for bill depth.
So we could change this to
be something like 10 to 20.
And we're going to see
that, as well, basically.
There we are.
So, so on and so forth.
It does that.
You can choose even
super dark colors, like,
if you wanted to have
brown, for instance.
What will it do?
I think it will actually
reverse the text if the color is
like-- it will do that for you.
It will, essentially, like, look
at contrast and say, like, oh.
This background color
is a bit too dark.
It's going to flip
the text color around.
And you can also disable that,
but it's just sort of there.
You can override that, as well,
with your own sort of styling,
but it's just a thing that
data color does for you.
And so that's a way you
can, sort of, make a,
sort of, like, heat map
for your table values.
And you can keep
going on, and there's
more functions in col_numeric.
There's col_factor.
It's all in help here.
Quantiles numeric, you know,
anything you want, you got it.
It's pretty nice.